the misfortunes continue for mehmet oz
the tv doctor turned pennsylvania senate
candidate we already knew that he wasn't
doing so well in the polls down by as
many as 11 points to democrat jon
fetterman and he of course had his
crudite grocery store video go viral he
also got caught lying about how he
supposedly only has two homes when he
actually has 10 but now one of his most
important allies in the race donald
trump is seemingly giving up on him and
making matters worse is fox news which
is also piling on according to sources
at rolling stone trump has said about oz
quote he's going to effing lose trump is
also dumbfounded that someone who has
been popular on tv for so long is
performing so poorly but really trump
should just look at a mirror on that one
since he was losing in the polls for
much of the 2016 and 2020 election cycle
so it can happen right uh trump asked
his advisors whether the polls may be
skewed or phony and they've had to tell
him things like this is not a matter of
the polls being rigged there are just
major problems with the campaign and
specifically with dr oz as a candidate
trump also doesn't get fetterman's
appeal to voters he thinks that he's in
poor shape and he spends too much time
in the basement just like joe biden did
apparently trump just doesn't get why
people would prefer an every man
caller type dude over an elitist
multi-millionaire in dr oz
trump however hasn't completely given up
on the race yet because he's going to be
heading over to pennsylvania on
september 3rd to do a rally for oz and
also for republican gubernatorial
candidate doug mastriano now if that
rally gets cancelled sometime between
now and then that's going to mean that
trump realizes there is no hope and
that's going to be the coup de grace in
the race master al masriano also is down
somewhere between 10 and 15 points so
trump may at some point decide to pull
the parachute and then you'll know that
this race is over as well as the
gubernatorial race and it's not just
trump turning away from oz even fox news
is doing it they ran a segment on dana
perino show last week covering dr oz's
latest gaffes the crudite video
fetterman trolling oz in a number of
different ways and it was just a very
unbalanced take you'd think that fox
news would give the advantage to the
republican as to how things went between
the two candidates but when you look at
this segment you realize no they're kind
of just piling on on dr oz's misfortunes
let's take a look at the clip in a viral
video you see dr oz he's walking around
a grocery store where he's talking about
how inflation is really hitting
americans hard and it's making things
more expensive in grocery stores
especially that crudite
i thought i'd do grocery shopping i'm at
weg nurse and my wife wants some
vegetables for crudites guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute and this
doesn't include the tequila
now fetterman attacked dr oz on twitter
as being out of touch noting most people
in pennsylvania call it a veggie tray
and the supermarket chain is called
wegmans not wagners and fetterman raised
over five hundred thousand dollars in
just 24 hours while giving out wegners
let them eat crudute bumper stickers dr
oz said look uh he was exhausted
campaigning when he made the video in
april and sometimes he even gets his
kids names wrong then fetterman attacked
dr oz for owning 10 properties with a
photo of a monopoly board with 10 homes
on one space tweeting pov you are dr oz
playing a board game he then noted that
monopoly was invented in new jersey a
swipe at dr oz for having lived in
jersey for three decades now dr oz
responded saying i purchased my homes
with my money you lived off your parents
until you were almost 50. get off the
couch john now look this is a battle
over likability the latest fox news poll
shows fetterman is viewed favorably by
49 of voters dr oz is viewed unfavorably
by 55 percent of voters and so they
really got to everything in that little
segment didn't they they got to the
grocery store gaff john fetterman's
response to it with the veggie tray and
then they got into the monopoly board
and the 10 houses on boardwalk and how
monopoly was invented in new jersey and
sure they showed dr oz with that tweet
trying to fire back but it fell flat
obviously fetterman has gotten the best
out of these exchanges and he knows the
troll game a lot better than mehmet oz
does so that's the latest on this race
it's been one of the most entertaining
races to follow and we can't just call
dr oz completely out of this at this
point everyone has to vote but we'll see
if the trend continues in this direction
if federer is able to really squash him
by going up 15 maybe 20 points in the
polls then we can start celebrating a
little bit early i'd say but everyone
has to vote and it's not a surefire
thing just yet but things are definitely
looking good for john fetterman
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below